après son voisin indien le népal se
retrouve à son tour ce merdier par le
cos vite 19 face à une situation
épidémique
hors de contrôle au manque de vaccins le
gouvernement népalais doit faire appel à
l'aide internationale en urgence avec
plus de 9000 cas en 24 heures sous la
seule journée du 6 mai voilà trois
semaines que le népal enregistrent des
records d'infection loin d'imaginer le
pire il ya encore un mois avec seulement
100 cas par jour pour plus de 30
millions d'habitants
le personnel médical n'est pas les lance
aujourd'hui un cri d'alarmé sur une
situation sanitaire qui risque d'empirer
dans les prochaines semaines nous sommes
sous préparer nous manquons de
ressources et nous manquons de capacité
pour accomplir tout ce que nous devons
surmonter si nous attendons encore
quinze jours nous allons assister à une
augmentation dangereuse du nombre de cas
à l'heure actuelle aucun hôpital ne
dispose de lits pour traiter des
patients atteints de lakovic 19
même s'il ya délit il ya une énorme
pénurie d'oxygène l'approvisionnement en
oxygène est un problème majeur pour
accueillir de nouveaux patients et nous
ne sommes même pas au sommet de cette
vague
la situation va empirer elle va vraiment
empirer face à cette flambée épidémique
et au manque de moyens
le gouvernement a imposé des confinement
partiel dans plusieurs districts du pays
mais les critiques pleuvent déjà sur le
premier ministre népalais sharma au lit
accusé d'avoir minimisé l'ampleur de la
crise sanitaire